bonjour madjara dit non merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france alors
on l'a dit un 1 mois de confinement en
lettonie est ce que vous trouvez cette
décision justifiée
en tant que professionnel l'abaissement
médicaux nous sommes tout à fait un
sacré tout se confond le confinement
reconnais sera de même et courra
jusqu'au 15 mai
ensuite pendant quatre semaines il y
aura des restrictions strictes instruire
les communautés c'est absolument
nécessaire pour a commencé à briser
cette vague de cas qui s'abat sur la
lettonie depuis environ une somme
arrivent chaque semaine le nombre de
contaminations double
le système de santé se retrouvent donc
submergés et la crise s'aggrave
car cela réduit la capacité du système
de santé de prendre en charge les
maladies chroniques et les maladies et
puis on se retrouve donc dans une
situation de concurrence pour les dix
cellules de soins intensifs
et cela accroîtrait le risque est du
taux de mortalité secondaires donc ce
taux de mortalité lié à d'autres
maladies qui auraient pu être traités si
le système de santé n'était pas accaparé
par l'aco vide et cela ne peut être
accepté dans un bon système de santé
mais nous manquons de personnel de santé
depuis déjà une décennie
c'est cet afflux sur le système 2 et
chanter de nouveau patient liés à la
coved
pourrait être difficile à prendre en
charge
depuis environ déjà une semaine les
professionnels de santé
je doive se tourner vers le traitement
des malades de la convient de plus tôt
que leurs autres centres d'occupation
tels que la recherche etc
un autre au point de préoccupation est
que malgré les restrictions il pourrait
y avoir une question de taux
d'acceptation de la communauté la
communauté est elle prête à collaborer à
suivre les restrictions
si ce confinement est efficace alors
nous pourrons utiliser la vague et
reprendre pied
d'après les estimations il faudrait
quatre à six semaines pour résoudre la
situation actuelle alors vous l'avez
dire de plus en plus de cas en lettonie
1200 cas en début de semaine cette mort
également enregistrés dans le pays
comment vous expliquer justement le le
retour des cas de plus en plus nombreux
chez ou en lettonie
[Musique]
dont le connaissions peut être tout seul
la réponse
c'est le manque d'activité tant la
campagne de vaccination
nous
aurions pu atteindre jusqu'à lorient à
environ 53 % de taux de vaccination
complet et environ 50% pour uniquement
les premières vaccinations c'est loin
d'être suffisant et cela débouche sur
ses taux élevé de nouvelles
contaminations
la seconde de pause
c'est ses notations de la queue vide ces
variants qui sont arrivés sur notre
territoire
les personnes qui avaient déjà reçu la
vaccination en début d'année
un niveau d'une égalisation tu baisses
et son se retrouvent vulnérables face
aux compute amis nation
vous l'avez dit un environ 50% des
lettons sont actuellement complètement
vaccinés
est ce qu'il ya une réticence
particulière des lettons vis-à-vis de
vis à vis du vaccin
je pense que dans une certaine mesure la
population et la victime d'un mouvement
mondial de désinformation qui joue un
grand rôle dans la prise de décisions de
nos citoyens
il ya également un manque de
compréhension de la situation au niveau
des communautés
il ya eu des manifestations contre la
communication du gouvernement
1 concernant l'épidémiologie la mise en
place de restrictions notamment au
printemps dernier
les anti vaccins expriment leur
protestation face aux décisions du
gouvernement
c'est un manque de compréhension des
problèmes de santé publique est en tout
cas c'est ce que nous pensons merci
maillard adina d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france merci d'avoir de
nous avoir parlé en à ce qui se passe
chez vous en lettonie je rappelle que
vous êtes président de l'association
lettone des radiologues merci beaucoup